hi reject nation I'm Greg Alba I'm John
Humphrey and I'm Ashley ed in there hey
we're gonna watch the trailer today
people you see over under patreon we do
TV show reactions for many of shows that
includes attack on Titan my hero
academia Full Metal Alchemist
Brotherhood as well as supernatural
Gotham Riverdale and John does music
video coverage but one of our topic
works here is whatever video you
requested was definitely do put up on
the youtubes today comes from
Lynnae our sweet darling all the way
from Texas she's a huge so tall she's a
huge wrestling fan and there's this new
movie out written directed by Stephen
Merchant called fighting with my family
that's based on the true story of the
wrestler Paige
all right I don't nothing about her
she's my favorite wrestler guys from the
wrestling that I love to watch let's
check it out guys
[Music]
that way family aren't you
we're not weird we don't how do you know
if you never because I know
[Music]
[Music]
few times thank you so much
what voice did you give us we want to be
the next few what's your names are you
walking around here interrupting the
rock you like you haven't seen the Sun
in 20 years if you like you just stepped
out of Oliver Twist you want some advice
here's a rocket bisection round explain
good morning Russell a delicious where
we see whether or not you get to go on
to WWE this is a short day
hello why do you wanna wrestle I'm the
toughest boxer than any group what we
shouldn't swear and wonderfully is
present sorry
[Music]
I call your name that means you'll be
coming with me to Florida page thank you
all very much
[Music]
no one deserves this more than that I
wish you the best son this is the end of
the line for you do you dislike
twelve-month anyway and your own sister
takes that way not just doing this for
you you're doing it for the family
[Music]
H I myself will come from a wrestling
family - I know exactly what it means to
you don't worry about me in the next one
do you first you
what sterling Johnson how are you
for me
[Music]
yeah and I've been days away it's funny
that we're getting a Vin Diesel joke in
this rock movie when they don't get
along a cop firmly what do you mean they
love weeds that are gonna make fast
night pretty soon yeah no spin off or
anything
this looks really fun acting like the
turn of events of the brother not
getting picked it looks like an
emotional movie yeah well it seems to
have an actual heart to it it's like
it's got that mixed in British dry wit
that Stephen Merchant has and you know
yeah these British characters - yeah I
like this like satirical version The
Rock's playing of himself may have some
more advice you want some advice here's
the rocks it biceps your mouth because
based on a true story I'm sure of course
the rock and play a younger version of
himself because he looks better than he
ever has like he's buffer now that he
ever was in wrestling yeah it's just
gonna have to go in and CG his muscles
so it's fun to see him making fun of
himself because a rock has such a good
sense of humor - well you know it's the
one place you get to see him go off and
kind of be an [ __ ] the movies like
captain charming right yeah I actually
like this plotline because what I've
discovered in the past year I don't know
like growing up with wrestling sometimes
playing on TV I was never a big fan of
it but I've discovered this past year
that there are people who are so loyal
and so dedicated to wrestling you know
like WWE WTF back then and to get a
movie where you can get into that
insight and mindset of those people who
are obsessed with wrestling and they
even aspiring to do it I think it's
coming out of a good timing I don't know
if it's just like I happen to suddenly
now be hearing about it everywhere I go
and I'm just sort of attracting these
conversations about wrestling but it
seems to be something that's very
prevalent again yeah and I think it's
really good timing on this movie because
it's easy to brush it off like Oh
fake when you see like this stuff work
they put into it your insanely dangerous
stuff these guys do for our
entertainment and they are performers -
they are actors and usually these kinds
of movies are normally very dramatic
like oscar-worthy movies yeah and this
just looks like a fun movie - yeah you
know I mean it doesn't look like super
super like intense dramatic it's like it
might be able to kind of give you both
yeah you know because it looks like it's
taking its story of the rise of page you
know pretty seriously but yeah with
enough kind of fun energy that it would
also be enjoyable and I gotta say like
WWE always surprises me with the movies
they come out with like I think the
first time I ever saw their bumper I
rolled my eyes but they have a pretty
decent track record or enough and they
like this look pretty interesting to
come at a wrestling story tuna to tell
like you know a female biopic is also
just a good choice for now because
wrestling is not a boys club sport as
much anymore no that's the other thing
it's like people like Lynnae who
requested this is a female
ya know I mean thank your old friends of
my girlfriend's obsessed with rap most
of the fellas I don't know I'm sure she
does like she's like a movie when she
heard about this movie she was like I'm
not a big fan of page I don't know if
I'm gonna watch this trailer like oh you
know ya wide caliber of talent here you
got Nick Frost and here is the daddy got
Vince Vaughn you gotta you know I'm
doing Johnson obviously Lena Headey
looking only seems like the wrestler do
you know this might be a newcomer I mean
the cool thing with biopic roles like
this is you just need someone who can
fulfill the shoes in terms of talent you
don't really need a famous person by the
time it is around them later like if she
know me like oh like the actresses
background yeah
oh that would be interesting to know
either way I'm sure this will actually
help us all gain an appreciation for
wrestling and
you know really I had close to no
interest in checking out this trailer
but yeah they come from Stephen Merchant
- that just makes me all the more
curious cuz now I'm sitting here going
is he like secretly a wrestling fan and
I just don't know that's the weird thing
is I'm finding I'm finding out more more
people who I know like I've known for a
long time are actually huge wrestling
fans I'm like how do I not know this
about so many people I know I wonder if
maybe it's gotten bigger than ever again
just because of the rise of things like
UFC and MMA and things like that like
just just fighting in general has kind
of come back into the center of the
public excitement for start again and so
I feel like maybe some of that could
have helped really JIT amaizing plus you
got dwayne johnson on top of the world
yeah and John Cena now in movies and
stuff I feel like wrestling has received
a lot of kind of extra inroads in the
later years that's Jeremy señores well
guys I'm excited for this Lynnae I hope
you have a happy Thanksgiving I know
that your grandma was kind of having a
little scary moment there but you said
she's doing better now I'm glad to hear
that and I hope that you guys cook one
fine-ass turkey when we talk reserved
she was honest about the crazy [ __ ] they
cook in Texas stuff so you're gonna have
one happy ass holiday love you my dear
thanks for requesting this is actually
you guys can subscribe to the reject
nation click that notification Bell
check us out on patreon we got a bunch
of stuff and Ashley Edna follow her on
Instagram where she is constantly
dressed like a lifeguard in a suit